okay here we are in chapter three linear
regression um which is obviously
important thing when you study
statistics so we're going to show you um
some of the tools for doing linear
regression and importantly we're going
to show you some new tools that
Jonathan's developed specifically for
this book um and for the islp package
that make specifying linear models much
easier okay thanks Trevor okay so um as
uh we'll see in most labs
um we talked and we talked a bit about
this in the first lab whenever you want
to use code in Python you have to find
it somewhere and that's the that's done
with an import statement now import
statements can be put anywhere in the
code but sort of good practice is to put
them all at the beginning um so we've
seen a few libraries in our last lab uh
we're going to import some of those same
objects and there's a new library that
fits linear aggression as well as
logistic regression which we'll see in
chapter 4 that's the stats models
package that is a sort of package for
fitting regression models in
R okay and as Trevor mentioned one of
the things we did for these Labs was try
to recreate uh try to create a way to to
make specifying regression models um
easier there are a few different ways to
do this in Python uh but we chose to do
something uh specific that was we felt a
little simpler and that's this this
model spec so we'll see a in a moment
how we use this to build design matrices
for the regression problem and that's
really besides fitting the model uh
specifying the design Matrix is one of
the important deciding what columns you
want to use what what effects what
interactions
Etc okay so let's jump right to um
linear
regression I better be careful and run
these cells so I have made the Imports
let's fit our first simple regression
model uh and see how this model
specification Works we're we're going to
use the uh the classic regression
example the Boston Housing data um and
we use this load data function from the
islp package most of the data sets we'll
use besides for deep learning can be
accessed with the low data function it
gives us a data frame um and uh with
these columns a description of the
variables uh can be found here or online
as
well okay so to fit a regression model
we need is design Matrix here let's make
a design Matrix by hand we're going to
have a column for an intercept and a
column for lstat this variable here is
stands for percent of the population of
lower social economic status not sure
exactly how that's measured but that's
what the documentation tells us each
observation is a sruct in in Boston oh
that's right the the response here is
medv which stands for median value and
that's the uh the median value of a h of
of a house in that particular census
District yeah okay so the way we fit
these models is given a response in a
design Matrix we're going to use this OS
method from the stats models package
which is an ordinar squares models we'll
fit it um with the fit
method and we'll take a look at uh you
know the usual summary of a regression
model that has coefficient estimates and
estimates of the standard error of
course the the t-statistic is the ratio
of these two and this is the you know
the P values here are tiny so there you
know there is some association between
um a parent association between lstat um
and and median value and by the way
summarize is one of the nice functions
written for the islp package um which
gives a nice compact summary compared to
the default summary which is rather big
and ugly yes you can see the default
summary below but we won't um we won't
Dell on it okay so um we're going to
have to create more design matrices and
more complicated design matrices so we
we're going to use this thing called
Model spec or model for model
specification and it uses this sort of
Paradigm we'll see later that is a
transformer for from the pyit learn
package so um these Transformers they
you can think of them as ways to um uh
to process features or sort of feature
engineering kits you'll notice in the
text we use the word model Matrix and
design Matrix
interchangeably yes um and so the these
Transformers they have these two methods
fit and transform
um that are used throughout whenever you
see a Transformer and this is our our
first example of one we'll see later
when we do principal components analysis
that it is another example of a
transform I just I just want to say
something here and that is that if you a
lot of time is often spent in building
up these model matrices to do regression
and it's tedious and especially when you
make transformations of variables and
you have interactions and things like
that you can spend a lot of time just
getting set up to do the regression and
Jonathan's created these tools that make
it much easier to do as you'll see and
especially as the examples get more
complicated yes yeah and another key
thing of course is if you were just to
make these design matrices by hand sort
of keeping track of what the columns are
and how they relate how everything else
is kind of is important being able to
manipulate them is useful like you might
want to you know drop one of the terms
of the Matrix of of a of a regression
model and being able to do that that's
those are some of the capabilities of
this this model spec yeah but we won't
touch on that today of course okay so
let's Jump Right In we want to fit a
regression with only a single feature so
we the way we specify the features in
the simplest case is just a list of
column names um and uh we use the we
apply the fit method to the Boston data
frame and what this will do is
essentially just check that there is an
lstat column in the Boston data frame
and recognize it that it's a that it's a
float and so when it creates a design
Matrix it'll just extract that column
and add that to the Matrix
if we had more columns we would um you
know it would have more columns to the
Des design Matrix we'll see that shortly
okay so doing this uh when we want to
actually construct the the design Matrix
or the model Matrix we called the
transform method um on a data frame
Boston in this case and this constructs
um the actual design Matrix or or model
Matrix and notice by default it put in
an intercept column which is something
if you did it manually you'd have to do
yourself just by default it just put in
the intercept column which is usually
what you want yes that's a good point um
you can turn it there's an option if you
don't want it you can get you can not
have it but most of the time we want an
intercept
them okay um let's see so I just one
small comment about this if you look at
when I constructed this this model
specification doesn't know anything
about the Boston data right it just has
the name of the column it's this part
here that the what we call the fit
method on Boston it inspects the Boston
data and recognize there actually is a
column called Alat and then knows what
to do with it when we call
transform
okay so
uh moving on um let's go on to uh the
next topic which will be multiple uh
which will be confidence intervals and
predicting at new points um so you know
as commonly we'll have a
another maybe some other census
districts that weren't included in the
fit or maybe if we think of this model
relating median value to lstat is
applicable to other areas we might go to
you know Philadelphia and find the
percent l l stat in those sentence and
try to predict there so um that's what
we'll do now so to do that we need to
provide the transform method a data
frame that has all the the necessary
variables in this case it just needs to
have lat and this transform will create
the design these rows of the design
Matrix matx corresponding to these
values of
lat I see so the the design object that
you created knows how to set up the
design Matrix and you've just given it a
new data frame and and it uses the
recipe you set up to do that that's
right yes yeah and so if you for more
complicated uh designs it's you know it
will produce the design Matrix in
exactly the same way as it did for the
original data when you fit the model um
that'll be important when some of the
Transformations get complicated uh um
like for for principal components or or
polinomial regression for
instance okay so and to actually get
confidence intervals or new predictions
that we rely on the stats models so this
get prediction method gives us um fitted
values for the uh at the new points uh
so those are the would be centers of our
confidence intervals and from the new
predictions method we can similarly get
confidence intervals oh wonderful so
that's simple linear regression
and the next section we'll deal with is
multiple linear
regression